le 10 décembre 1948 la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme
adoptée est derrière ces droits
fondamentaux des individus un juriste
français rené cassin vous êtes donc l'un
des auteurs de cette déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme
oui peut même dire qu'elle me doit son
nom au lendemain de la seconde guerre
mondiale l'objectif de ce texte est
ambitieux unir tous les pays autour
d'une volonté faire en sorte que la
barbarie ne se reproduise plus
cette déclaration constitue la
protestation de la conscience humaine
contre les massacres et les injustices
dont trop d'êtres humains ont été
victimes garantir les droits de l'homme
une notion primordiale pour préserver la
paix est depuis toujours c'est le combat
de rené cassin en 1940 il rejoint la
france libre du général de gaulle à
londres
je ne pouvais pas eu égard à maîtriser
supporter l'idée d'une france écrasé et
de la juge quiche bafouée à londres en
pleine guerre
le juriste prépare la paix il rédige la
charte de la france libre et une fois la
guerre terminée
c'est donc logiquement qu'il représente
la france à la commission des nations
unies pour rédiger la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme
un combat pour la paix qui sera
récompensée en 1968 avec le prix nobel
de la paix
à 81 or rené cassin était de ces
français peu connus de leurs
compatriotes
un télégramme venue d'oslo a mis fin à
cette sorte d'injustice
une récompense qui va émouvoir le
juriste jusque là dans l'ombre des
grands politiques chez et plus après
avoir deux fois fait la guerre
représenter un instant seulement cette
pelle france nous gérons toute ma vie
aura été utile merci en 1976 à l'âge de
89 ans rené cassin moeurs juriste
professeur de droit membre du conseil
constitutionnel combattants résistants
négociateurs internationale toutes ces
casquettes avec un seul but maintenir et
préserver la paix un combat honoré par
la france en 1987 date où son corps et
transférées au panthéon
[Musique]